la cour d'assises spéciale de bordeaux a
rendu son verdict ce soir dans la sphère
de la tacc par un commando d'une caserne
de la légion étrangère en corse un
légionnaire avait été tué les deux
hommes l'un était acquitté l'autre un an
de prison avec sursis
les syndicats avaient dit oui au
protocole d'accord avec le gouvernement
la coordination dit non et fait défiler
les infirmières dans les rues de paris
et des grandes villes de france
une nouvelle pièce au dossier des
prisons un document dans ce journal sur
la vie au centre de détention de muret
une prison dont les détenus sont là pour
longtemps
certains pour leurs vies entières
campent ans lille comme en ville ils le
disent à paroles et à visage découvert
madame monsieur bonsoir la cour
d'assises spéciale de bordeaux a rendu
son verdict ce soir dans la sphère de la
tacc par un commando d'une caserne de la
légion étrangère en corse
un légionnaire avait été souvenons nous
tués dans cette attaque un autre
grièvement blessé dans le box les deux
inculpés n'était plus poursuivi que pour
complicité
félix tommasini a été acquitté et
charles pieri condamné à un an de prison
avec sursis sur place dominique
verdeilhan trois heures vingt de
délibéré six jours de débats dix minutes
qui viennent peut-être d'effacer plus de
cinq ans de soupçons dans le calme dans
le recueillement dans les larmes de joie
famille et amis de felice tomasi et
charles pieri quittent la cour d'assises
de bordeaux
le verdict résonne encore dans leurs
oreilles felice tomasi a déclaré non
coupable de l'ensemble des faits dont il
était accusé
felice tommasi après cinq ans et sept
mois de préventive est acquitté charles
pieri joseph moura de chiny et satie
sont condamnés pour transport et
détention d'armes illégale
à un an de prison avec sursis tous trois
ont bénéficié de circonstances
atténuantes à la lecture du verdict
à 18h15 énorme satisfaction des deux
accusés mais aussi les avocats qui voit
dans ce jugement
un immense espoir pour les 40 autres
prisonniers corses
actuellement encore en détention cette
diffusion justice nous attendions depuis
longtemps de plus de 2 puis de 5 ans
nous l'avons nous avons obtenu
seule déclaration je vais même
soulagement même émotion chez les
parents des deux corses
si un de ces distractions
je pense et qui maintenant aux miens je
pense qu'ils en vivent comme enfant hier
l'avocat général avait requis dix ans de
réclusion criminelle reconnaissant
néanmoins que le dossier d'instruction
était mal ficelé et que seule la
complicité pouvait être retenue contre
tomasi et thierry ce matin m mattei l'un
des avocats avait dit au président
gaubert la corse veut la paix alors
donnez nous la justice vous êtes notre
dernière chance avant longtemps ce
procès ni celui de la compromission ni
celui de la menace mais celui de la
vraie justice
un appel qui a été entendu à bordeaux un
jugement qui ce soir a dû être entendu
en corse
oui justement voyons tout de suite
comment ce verdict a été accueilli
encore sur place sa nièce poilhes
aujourd'hui mérigeau tomasi a été
acquitté
la joie dans les rues de bastia jusqu'au
bout ils ont expiré plus attendre
l'acquittement répétait-il sans vraiment
y croire
tomasi a quitté un an de prison avec
sursis pour thierry alors que le flnc
est reconduit à quelques semaines la
trêve des attentats
on commence à penser que quelque chose
peut changer en corse
je m'endorme initial
l'étude note aussi qu' totalement vide
qu'il était le synonyme d'une époque
nous espérons révolue à savoir on
faisait n'importe quoi pour essayer
d'éliminer des militants nationalistes
et vous y avez une machination au niveau
de l'instruction et il y avait des
sévices au niveau du commissariat de
police bien nous espérons que ce verdict
permettra avec notre initiative qui a
été prise en particulier par les
nationalistes de participer un règlement
politique de la question au corps et
déjà on prévoit le retour au pays de
félix tomasi a quitté aujourd'hui à
bordeaux après cinq ans et demi de
détention préventive
au terme de trois semaines de conflit
maintenant ce sont encore les bienfaits
des infirmières qui font la une de
l'actualité de ce soir à l'appel de leur
coordination elles ont manifesté cet
après-midi à paris et dans plusieurs
villes de france à paris elle était
entre 13000 a défilé selon la police
vingt mille selon les organisateurs de
la manifestation
et pourtant la nuit dernière les
syndicats exception faite de la cgt
avait accepté un protocole d'accord
portant sur les augmentations de
salaires mais visiblement cet après midi
donc les syndicats minoritaires dans la
profession il faut le savoir ont été
désavoués par les infirmières qui entend
ainsi montrer qu'elles continuent leur
combat
alain ou risque atmosphère bon enfant
mais bon enfant en colère des chansons
où il est question de monsieur evin
ministre de la santé des slogans du
genre
notre colère n'est pas un feu de paille
elle ira à son terme et puis surtout
cette accusation
les syndicats sont contre nous
les infirmières les aides-soignantes
étaient dans la rue un peu partout en
france pour réclamer je cite un
véritable statut une reconnaissance de
leur profession les salaires facettes en
second plan
dans leur valorisation de la profession
il n'y a rien eu au niveau de la
revalorisation j'insiste là dessus il ya
simplement eu une manne de quelque de
quelques de quelques francs qui a été
distribué de quelques centaines de
francs qui était distribué pour faire
taire les gens
et pour mettre l'opinion publique entre
nous et notre formation avant tu sois un
politique c'est un mouvement apolitique
un mouvement corporatiste un jeu
puisqu'il ce qu'on saigne et les
syndicats statut et à votre avis c'est
ridicule je pense qu'ils ne sont pas
allés suffisamment loin dans les
négociations avec monsieur et 20 et on
vous l'a vu de contenu pour nous je
pense que la lutte continue à partir du
moment où statuer formation le studio
pas reconnu
d'autre part il faut pas oublier que les
syndicats ne représentent que 7 à 8 %
notre profession en tête du cortège des
personnalités du comité de soutien aux
infirmières le professeur léon
schwartzenberg ou joëlle kauffmann en
province comme à paris des infirmiers a
lancé des appels aux usagers pour qu'ils
les rejoignent ici à bordeaux par
exemple à lille
plus de 2500 personnes étaient dans la
rue un peu partout il faut noter une
forte participation des aides soignantes
leur sort est lié à celui des
infirmières distel pénible affaire
concernant une petite fille de 4 ans à
rennes johanna qui a été retiré à la
garde de ses parents qu'il éduquées
selon des principes inspirés du nazisme
ce qui avait obligé la daf à intervenir
mais depuis huit mois
la petite fille n'a toujours pas trouvé
de famille d'accueil et cela malgré des
propositions et devant cette lenteur à
la fois administratives et judiciaires
son grand père avait décidé aujourd'hui
d'agir au risque de se mettre dans
l'illégalité j'en paye eu cet homme
vendre et louer bien décidé à se battre
pour voir sa petite fille johanna malgré
l'interdiction du juge pour enfants il
n'a pourtant rien à se reprocher c'est
lui qui en févrie alerte la justice à
propos d'éducation non conformiste donné
à johanna par sa mère et son beau-père
le juge décide de placer l'enfant dans
un centre de la direction des affaires
sanitaires et sociales la dass le grand
père au début voit souvent johanna
jusqu'au jour où le juge lui supprime
son droit de visite
andré louis après avoir patienté
plusieurs semaines décident de passer
outre si on me retire complètement le
droit de la voir parce qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai fais une pression ce n'est que
rattraper ce que je n'avais pas fait
avant je n'ai pas cette pression avant
de tout ce qu'on a su cesser les
journalistes qui ont tué des
informations par sa mère et son concubin
mais moi je n'ai pas parlé je ne voulais
pas déranger la justice on m'a
d'ailleurs bien conseillé de m'écraser
andré-louis en appelle maintenant à
françois mitterrand pour que sa petite
fille quitte le centre et soit placé
dans une famille d'accueil le
gouvernement négocie sur le plan social
on l'a vu tout à l'heure avec les
infirmières ils négocient également au
parlement
ne bénéficiant pas de la majorité
absolue vous le savez bien ce matin il a
réussi à faire adopter la première
partie de son budget des recettes de
l'état pour 1989 grâce à l'abstention
des communistes et les centristes
les centristes qui avaient obtenu que la
tva sur les produits de luxe soit ramené
de 33 à 28 % et puis dans la nuit donc
avant l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune avait été voté grâce à l'appui
des communistes et à l'abstention des
centristes en quelques chiffres
rappelons qu'elle est la nature est la
cible de cet arbre l'impôt sur la
fortune s'applique à partir de 4
millions de francs il comprend quatre
tranches avec des taux allant de 0,5 à
1,1 pour cent
la tranche de 1,1 pour cent porte sur
les fortunes supérieures à 20 millions
de francs
elle devrait rapporter 200 millions
supplémentaires
les socialistes qui l'ont fait voter ont
fait passer deux autres amendements lisf
et l'impôt sur le revenu ne devront pas
dépasser 70% de l'imposition total ils
ont obtenu aussi deux exonérations les
brevets professionnels et les actions
des salariés dans leur entreprise à
hauteur d'un million de francs
ces exonérations s'ajoute à celle du
projet lui-même
l'outil de travail les biens
professionnels quand la personne détient
plus du quart du capital et les oeuvres
d'art
quant aux centristes ils ont fait voter
un amendement qui permet aux ménages
assujettis de déduire de lits sf 1000
francs par personne à charge
notez encore au congrès des cadres de la
cfe cgc le président paul mark kelly qui
attaquent violemment le ministre de
l'économie et des finances pierre
bérégovoy ils lui reprochent des
déclarations paranoïaque je cite
monsieur marc kelly liant
systématiquement la progression du
pouvoir d'achat des salariés à celle de
l'inflation alors que dans le même temps
dit-il l'état n'hésite pas lui à
augmenter son budget de plus de 2 et
demi pour cent quand au cnpf il n'est
pas épargnée non plus le cnpf selon
monsieur mark kelly est toujours prêt à
tendre la main au gouvernement pour
recevoir plus et payer toujours - les
salariés sont d'âge ipsos ce journal du
dimanche sur la popularité du chef de
l'état et du premier ministre en octobre
par rapport à septembre
eh bien monsieur
mitterrand perd un point 50% de
satisfaits contre 51 au mois de
septembre
monsieur michel rocard quant à lui perd
trois points 44% de satisfaits contre 47
en septembre étrangers maintenant en
algérie la volonté d'ouverture affichée
par le gouvernement algérien est pris au
mot par une partie de la population
algérienne
au travers de ces organisations
professionnelles ou encore dans le
milieu étudiant
des réunions publiques de contestation
ont lieu aujourd'hui en algérie ce qui
était encore impensable il ya quinze
jours sur place bruno le dreff gens
tournent comme un frémissement 250
étudiants manifestent dans l'université
de bab ezzouar la plus importante
d'alger 250 étudiants sur 20000 c'est
peu c'est beaucoup ils défilent sans
être inquiété nous pouvons les filmer
librement
c'est nouveau une dizaine d'étudiants
entamé une grève de la faim on les
laisse faire c'est du jamais vu
après les journées d'émeutes et la
sanglante répression qui a suivi le
président chadli l'avait exigé le pays
doit s'ouvrir à plus de démocratie
les résistances les craintes les doutes
sont nombreux mais aujourd'hui
quelques-uns aux spas relais santé
parfois abattus froidement dans la rue
ou bien mal 2003 et on l'a torturé
sauvagement demande dans les locaux des
services de sécurité
on a maltraité des enfants et quel que
soit le système qui doit ya voir prendre
ensuite il faut que ça disparaisse pour
la première fois de leur histoire des
professeurs se réunissent en dehors du
très officiel cadre syndical les morts
des journées d'émeutes leur ont donné
comme à d'autres du courage un peu
partout dans le pays
des voix s'élèvent elles en ont la
possibilité
aujourd'hui il ya les jeunes qui ont
manifesté qui ont peut-être dès les tout
jeunes qui ont qui avaient des
motivations personnelles dont la presse
a beaucoup parlé mais maintenant on
réfléchit beaucoup et les moins jeunes
évidemment eux pose des problèmes que il
n'avait pas eu l'occasion de poser
il faut le dire depuis 26 ans depuis
l'accession de l'algérie à
l'indépendance il y à bien en algérie un
début d'ouverture politique
à preuve dans le journal télévisé on
peut entendre la voix de la rue
réclamant des réformes politiques en
particulier la possibilité d'existence
d'autres partis que le fln une nouvelle
fois du jamais vu
mieux encore ce reportage critiquant les
méfaits de la bureaucratie la télévision
algérienne est l'expression officielle
du gouvernement
de tels reportages ne sont possibles
qu'avec l'accord des plus hautes
autorités politiques
la société algérienne se trouve
aujourd'hui en état d' asphyxie son
économie dans une très mauvaise
situation pour éviter la mort lente
une seule solution l'ouverture ou bien
le président chadli et ce qu'ils veulent
avec lui une ouverture politique et
économiques l'emportent et alors
l'algérie devrait pouvoir mieux
développer son potentiel industriel ou
bien ils sont battus et le pays risque
de s'enfoncer un peu plus dans la
spirale infernale de la dette de la
dépendance économique voire même
politique
la politique étrangère ce soir c'est
également une affaire de coeur dans les
deux sens du terme d'ailleurs pour le
premier ministre grec andreas papandreou
qui est rentré dans son pays aujourd'hui
après deux mois d'absence soigner à
londres pour une grave maladie cardiaque
à londres où l'avait suivi sa nouvelle
et jeune compagne de 35 ans sa cadette
ce que visiblement ses supporters
politiques qui lui ont pardonné si l'on
en juge par l'accueil qu'il a reçu cet
après midi sur l'aéroport d'athènes
gilles rabin
il est de retour après deux mois
d'absence avec son vieux coeur de 69 ans
entièrement remis à neuf chez les
anglais elle est de retour elle aussi
imitera liany son bel amour de 34 ans
une ancienne hôtesse de l'air que le
protocole retient sur la coupe et la
présence de celle par qui le scandale
est arrivé
suffirait en effet à rappeler à cette
foule enthousiaste qu'à londres
malgré le talent de ses chirurgiens
andréas papandréou n'est pas parvenu à
régler tous ses problèmes de coeur
cette voiture que la foulée score ne
ramènera pas le premier ministre grec
chez lui son épouse légitime refuse
toujours de quitter le palais conjugale
dans l'antiquité déjà zzzzzz devait
descente de l'olympe pour flirter avec
vénus dans les affaires que nous aimons
à suivre lorsque l'actualité quotidienne
temps à les faire oublier en voici une
qui concerne le marché unique européen
de 1981
d'ici là il faudra vous le savez que les
12 pays la communauté européenne et
harmoniser tout leur réglementation
c'est un travail de titan
si l'on se réfère par exemple aux 20 ans
qui ont été nécessaires pour faire en
sorte que la réglementation européenne
sur les confitures a priori simple à
faire et à concevoir soi la même partout
et bien donc détrompez vous
la signature définitive n'a été apposées
que dimanche dernier dans l'indifférence
quasi générale d'ailleurs delphine de
las le plus facile avec la confiture
c'est encore d'essayer de la manger le
plus proprement possible
gourmandise pour les uns la confiture
est devenu le cauchemar des spécialistes
du marché européen
chaque ingrédient fruits sucre gélifiant
que laurent a fait l'objet d'âpres
discussions
en 1979 une première directive
européenne est votée mais en 88 le
dossier n'est toujours pas bouclée sur
ce dossier confiture on peut chiffrer le
temps 15 20 ans pour aboutir à la
situation d'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
si on intègre aussi bien les
fonctionnaires français que tous les
fonctionnaires de la communauté aux 100
personnes à peu près ont vu d'aussi
confiture qui constitue une masse de
papier étonnante dont vous avez un
échantillon ici pour ce qui nous
concerne la difficulté trouver des
normes communes pour douze pays ayant
chacun une tradition bien particulière
dans le domaine tant pour la fabrication
que pour l'appellation par exemple en
portugais il est pratiquement impossible
de traduire le mot marmelade puisque il
n'a pas d'équivalence en portugais et en
portugais une marmelade est un produit
qui est fabriqué à partir d'un fruit qui
s'appelle le coin alors que la marmelade
est un produit définies par la directive
européenne comme un produit fait à base
d'agrumes
la france est plutôt bien placé la
qualité de sa confiture est conforme aux
textes ces étiquettes protection du
consommateur oblige sont parfaitement
réglementaire on suit concerne les
procès ça ça n'a pas changé grand chose
les français étaient déjà habituées à
faire un produit de bonne qualité
comparativement à ce qui se passait en
europe mais depuis huit ans on peut dire
que tous les pays se conforme à la
directive et
toutes les ventes de confiture qui se
font dans les pays sont conformes du
côté fabrication comme du côté
étiquetage aujourd'hui la confiture
européenne existe mais il n'est plus
question de consacrer autant d'années
aux différents dossiers qui s'accumulent
à bruxelles on accélère les procédures
dans cinq ans tout devrait être réglé
l'industrie de la lunette tient salon à
paris en ce moment dans ce secteur est
bien la france est leader c'est le bon
point économiques de cette semaine nous
sommes allés rendre visite aux plus
grands fabricants français qui cherche
innove et exporte dans le monde entier
jacques deviere en 1988 une paire de
lunettes ça se conçoit et se fabrique à
la fois grâce aux technologies les plus
modernes mais aussi toujours à la main
pièce par pièce bésicles binocles
lorgnons depuis des siècles on porte des
lunettes
aujourd'hui une personne sur quatre dans
le monde et presbytes un marché énorme
dominée par une société française
essilor ses usines fabriquent chaque
année des centaines de milliers de
monture dont 80% pour l'exportation et
des verts dont la production est
impressionnante
empilés les uns sur les autres il
représente chaque jour l'équivalent de
trois tours eiffel
d'abord les montures elles sont créées
dessiné par huit personnes dans un
atelier ont choisi les matières les
formes les couleurs tous les ans des
nouveaux modèles
une collection c'est environ 120 modèles
que nous renouvelons un rythme d'environ
50% par an c'est à dire chaque année
nous sortons 60 nouveaux modèles dans
les laboratoires on étudie les
performances des matériaux pour créer
des nouveaux verres on transforme des
matières minérales ou organiques par
exemple pour réaliser un verre composite
avec un noyau de polymères c'est à dire
du plastique
entouré de deux structures de verre nos
axes de recherche sont principalement la
mise au point de produits de meilleure
qualité qui ont des propriétés amélioré
de résistance aux chocs de résistance à
la rayure de légèreté c'est à dire de
faire des verts confortable mais il y a
tout un autre domaine de recherche qui
concerne la physiologie de la vision par
exemple et les astronautes américains ou
les cosmonautes soviétiques utilisent
nos verres varilux varilux le plus bel
exemple de réussite inverse inventé en
1959 qui a mis au rancart les vieilles
lunettes à double foyer est porté
aujourd'hui par plus 50 millions de
personnes dans le monde
c'est le document de notre édition de ce
soir on dit parfois des choses fausses
ou mal vérifiées sur l'univers des
prisons françaises le reportage que nous
vous présentons ce soir est donc
particulièrement intéressant puisqu'ils
nous a été permis de visite est très
librement et de nous entretenir tout
aussi librement avec les détenus du
centre de détention de muret près de
toulouse haute garonne dans cette prison
est bien les détenus ne sont pas de
passage c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
ils ont tous été condamnés à de longues
très longues peines ou même à la
perpétuité
comment vit-il que pense-t-il de leur
sort en quête de thierry calmette et
gilbert usa après le verdict voici le
centre de détention à l'établissement
pas comme les autres pour y purger une
peine de 15 ans 20 ans ou perpétuité
les longues peines koch le calendrier
tous les jours mais compte en année un
premier combat vaincre la tentation du
suicide
c'est très dur sont minimes oui c'est
minime parce qu'il vaille c'est jamais
jamais cantine à sortir oui pour lui la
ligne la patate et alors ils se
demandent un moment il dit mais pourquoi
je vois là pour proches facile pourquoi
je fais cela puisqu'il faut toujours
recommencée et jerry yang ou à muret
vivent près de 700 détenus dont 50
condamné à perpétuité
une prison moderne privation de liberté
parfois définitivement
mais selon la loi droit à l'éducation au
travail à la santé
ici le visiteur ressent l'obsession
lancinante le corps la forme physique
parfois à l'excès pour combien de temps
pour tata lingots sont atteints et
combien d'autres pays
et c'est comme ça que vous avez attrapé
ses muscles un luxe est salle de gym un
défouloir qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
si on a les privilèges rapport à
certains endroits mais ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que s'est étalée sur des
années le problème sur des années et
l'ailé gabon il si vous voulez sur des
années ils perdent tout toute notion de
la possibilité de réinsertion la
réinsertion je vous dis c'est pas
l'haltérophilie est positif c'est à dire
de retrouver sa famille dehors
la famille est fatigue de façon à la
force de venir au bout de si vous voulez
vous de cinq sites ou 8 ans qui aurait
quelqu'un va venir va venir vous voir
ces troubles est obligatoirement les
biens se brise et c'est sur ces choses
là qui sont concrètes
là on vous a montré un côté bon d'accord
il ya des haltères il ya pas mal de
choses ça nous amènera rien soulage la
sortie même après vingt ans ils
sortiront un jour alors à muret les
détenus occupent 400 postes de travail
formation professionnelle et
apprentissage de la vie sociale certains
ateliers gérés par des entreprises
privées développent des techniques de
pointe mais le taux de chômage à
l'extérieur réduit les possibilités
d'emploi et de rééducation
l'atelier qui fabrique ces baignoires de
thalassothérapie représente une
exception
l'artisanat chargé de symbole mais moins
valorisants demeure une source
d'activité solide la réinsertion n'est
pas l'unique objectif de cette industrie
pénitentiaire à muret tout se paie
salaire maximum de 1000 francs un
monstre beaucoup de gens pensent
on n'est pas dans une 3 étoiles on a
peut-être le dire aussi à beaucoup de
gens sauf cofidis la télévision ils sont
en prison pour la télé sont ceux ci solo
il faut pas oublier qu'on n'ait pas eu
les télévisions on est sympa gravissant
n'a rien de gratuit siens piscine en
maison d'arrêt
oui son fonds l'argent obligation
d'acheter le récepteur de télévision
pouvoir améliorer l'ordinaire pouvoir
cantine et c'est à dire acheter des
cigarettes des journaux
le superflu indispensable pour atténuer
les angoisses et les fantasmes lorsque
vient le soir ça fait deux ans de prison
personne ne peut véritablement savoir ce
que c'est vous en sortez jamais la
prison parce que à l'intérieur de vous
même quand vous serez dehors vous la
porterez et que la souffrance quand ils
vous arrivent aussi quelque chose la
souffrance de la porte et c'est une
punition elle n'entre pas dans les dents
les punitions qui infligent un jury
populaire
vous l'avez ou c'est quelque chose qui
se rajoute la crainte
il faut réapprendre à vivre en société
et respecter le règlement intérieur de
la prison des règles fermes mais non
brutale la faute ce juge dans le
prétoire
le tribunal de la prison sanction le
mitard juste à côté
certains ils passent plus de 45 jours
faire du mitard 6e marqués d'encre rouge
repousser de plusieurs années la date
d'une éventuelle permission de sortie
cette permission une véritable carotte
pour les condamnés et l'administration
sans elle pas de modus vivendi pour
faire la moitié de la panne et la moitié
l'appel porter pâtes c'est 15 ans
je pense qu'en temps après je peux
sortir en permission
depuis 1986 j'ai fini 7e peine de 20 ans
que j'ai pris à saint-etienne pour des
hold up je vous dis que j'ai pas fait
est bon match ça en permission
tous les trois mois c'est un contrat oui
bon bah moi je suis un homme réguler
nous ayons connaissent le savent
d'ailleurs par conséquent bon match je
sors je vais travailler chez moi parce
que je travaillais toujours pas de ma
famille oui cette année à muret deux
détenus sur 100 ne sont pas revenus
après une permission
c'est une certaine réussite l'école en
prison un autre moyen de s'en sortir
mais les crédits resteras limite le
nombre des professeurs et décourage les
élèves les éducateurs prennent en charge
les difficultés sauf une seule le manque
de liberté c'est un feuilleton qui se
poursuit les baleines coincé par la
banquise en alaska l'une d'entre elle
n'est pas réapparue depuis ce matin et
les secours ne sont toujours pas arrivés
sur place cote reste les sauveteurs
l'avait baptisé os ou bonne en anglais
parce que le ballet nous avait les prend
à vif à force de frapper sous la glace
pour aller respirer depuis hier soir il
a disparu
seuls ses compagnes ou bennett et crosby
re continue à venir régulièrement mais
leur cadence toutes les deux minutes
maintenant
et signe de leur essoufflement
sur la banquise les sauveteurs n'ont pas
lâché prise ceci après avoir tronçonné
utilisent des appareils à dégeler par
brassage de l'eau un système qui
théoriquement empêche la glace de se
reformer dans les trous il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il fait moins 30 degrés dans
les airs deux hélicoptères grues à tour
de rôle progresse très lentement en
brisant la banquise avec le pilon de
béton ces baleines grises ont réussi là
où souvent la diplomatie échoue et le
monde entier s'apitoie sur leur sort
l'urss a même offert un brise glace et
un représentant de greenpeace est arrivé
demain avec des enregistrements de
chants de baleines pour guider les
cétacés vers le large
toujours est il qu'ils ont déjà franchi
800 m de trou en trou mais même si la
météo annonce un radoucissement il reste
encore des dizaines et les dizaines de
kilomètres pour arriver vers la zone non
glacée salvatrice sport pour terminer
chypre france de football comptant pour
la qualification de la prochaine coupe
du monde de football donc à quelques
minutes de la fin actuellement c'est la
france qui mène 1 0 je crois dominique
écoutez bien regardez bien ceci est la
seule action dangereuse des france en 43
minutes papin échoue à gauche du gardien
chypriote
on croit rêver enfin plutôt être en
plein cauchemar un cauchemar qui prend
enfin une minute de la mi-temps
seulement vous verrai termine au fond
des filets un bon travail de franck
sauzée bien relayé par papin ouf il
était temps
la france c'était aller au mondial 82
grâce à sa victoire 7 0 sur chip on est
cette fois bien loin du compte au moment
du bilan
souhaitant qu'on n'est pas pour
départager à tenir compte de cette
différence de but voilà maintenant les
résultats du tiercé pour terminer
puisque les pronostics vous sont
communiquées maintenant tous les samedis
soirs je vous le rappelle à 19h30 par
pierrette brès je me contente donc des
résultats de cet après-midi tiercé 5 4
16 rapports 8177 francs et 50 centimes
et puis le quartier qui va suivre
derrière vous ajoute